hello i'm cole sprouse and i'm going
undercover on the internet and this is
actually me pornhub.com twitter cole
sprouse
how do you feel about basically being
killed off of friends critics would
agree that Ross was never really the
most present father and so it doesn't
surprise me too much
next cole sprouse why do you have bread
in your pocket i answered this ok why
don't you have bread in your pocket
Betty Cooper do you think in the next
part of the season we will see Betty and
Jughead as the investigative duo again
yes in the second half of the season you
will definitely see them start to get
much more investigated and will Betty
meet Gladys at some point that is
something you're currently exploring
right now
Debbie cake at PSN asks what's your
opinion on pineapple on pizza I like it
sweetness
saltiness I don't know why people hate
on it so much just relax don't get other
people's yards enjoy yourself there are
bigger fish to fry like anchovies on
pizza it's disgusting it's actually me
what's going on here this is the
happiest Jughead has ever looked even if
it's F P it's called love baby that's
what's going on there - shirtless men
running through the hall it's called
romance google it on the net what
exactly makes cole sprouse so attractive
to so many people you just look slightly
above average and I know people in my
high school that looked like him that
don't get any action or attention no
offense to him at all I'm just very
curious I already have an identical twin
so let's not compare me anymore okay
especially two more high school students
I know I'm playing 16 and I'm 26 but I
can't do it anymore
all right I've done action or attention
that sounds like a damn problem and not
a me problem what makes cole sprouse so
attractive
it's the wit it's the charm it's this
light pink shirt yahoo answers dylan and
Cole Sprouse differences in similarities
what are four similarities in four
differences between Dylan and Cole
Sprouse well first off we like to be
referred to as Cole and dylan sprouse
not the other way around
that's a similarity we both share the
other similarity is our voice it's
incredibly similar it's probably the
most identical part about us except for
our nipple size which is also exactly
the same I am much more muscular than my
brother and my jawline is much more
strapping which we all agree on that
should be enough submitted Cora it's not
always present in your opinion is Cole
Sprouse a good person absolutely not
what should I take into consideration
when writing a biography about Cole
Sprouse perhaps every injury that I've
ever received as a child which no doubt
scarred me for the rest of my life was
in part thanks to my brother like two
concussions the falling off my roof when
I was nine years old
hey thanks still appreciate it in
Riverdale Archie said there were three
musketeers I'm Betty corrected him by
saying there were four she said there
were four meaning Prix Veronica I means
Archie Betty Jughead in someone else who
was the fourth person visit Paulie the
fourth person was dylan dylan sprouse
the other fourth person was probably
Vegas Vegas the dog or maybe it's just a
plot hole submit Wikipedia it's actually
me and 2001 Cole began appearing in
episodes of NBC's television sitcom
friends as Ross Geller's son Ben this
role was his first role in which he did
not appear with his brother honestly our
appearance as the same character was
sort of dependent on how much screen
time we had in friends for example my
role was not to present they only really
needed to hire one twin because both of
us were incredibly expensive
Sprouse is a fan of comics and worked at
the Los Angeles comic store meltdown
that's true in the year between the
sweet life log deck and my foray into
higher education my brother and I both
worked as interns at meltdown where I
started doing some photography and I
also work behind the counter selling
comics for a bit recipes mocha among his
undergraduate work he unearthed a mask
of Dionysus on a dig in Bulgaria yeah I
was an archaeological student in
university I specialized in something
called predictive models for
archaeological sites so I would plot on
a this is gonna get tacky to get ready
for this
I would plot on a 3d Lance that were
previously discovered and I'd pulled
criteria for water view shed and it
would then be used in fuel inquiry into
surveys for five weeks with a toothpick
and maybe a spoon
I eventually unearthed something and it
happened to be a mask which is
simultaneously exciting and terrifying
if you've seen Jim Carrey's movie the
masks posted Sprouse will star in five
feet apart a romantic drama set to be
released in March 2019 he plays a cystic
fibrosis patient who falls in love with
a girl played by Haley Liu Richardson
for the same disease yes that is true
Thank You Wikipedia and for all of you
watching who are using Wikipedia
consistently for all of your projects
even though you know you shouldn't
donate $3 YouTube
what's the model of his camera I really
want to know somebody tell me please in
that shot that is a cannon AE one that's
kind of the bread and butter student
camera for 35 millimeter it's film you
can get a pretty cheap canon AE one body
and a lens if you go to your local
camera store or online or I'll sell you
mine depending on the price submit and
there were some fruit in the trees and I
said Kendall please could you reach for
a fruit this cole sprouse secretly an
ASM artist or something ASMR that's
that's the one where people go really
close to the mic and chew I don't think
I hate a subculture of the internet more
than people getting really close to the
microphone and eating why would you do
that
so people love it they love it and they
make more money than me and that's the
most upsetting part hmmm more Twitter
why did you delete your tumblr it was my
whole life I lived for it well tumblr
recently stopped allowing us to post
nudity so then I decided it would be
best if I stopped how do you feel when
teenage fanfiction riders invaded the
Riverdale scriptwriter room well that
happened episode 1 season 1 so I was
primed for that sort of discourse from
the very beginning posted Jack Warren
asks did anyone ever meet Dylan and Cole
Sprouse for the Danimal contest or was
it all a lie no it no it did happen and
it was incredibly awkward we were told
we were gonna have a nice gift to give
to the kid who just turned 16 and got
himself a truck but danimals gave us a
skateboard which was weird because he
already had a means of locomotion that
was much better than skateboarding
around he had just gone hunting I'm
pretty sure there was a dead deer in the
back of the truck that was a strange
period of my life Hannah also known as
at chunk Bueller has asked do you ever
think Dylan Cole do the twin handshake
from The Suite Life of Zack and Cody
just for old times sake yes when you pay
us Instagram ah the camera duels is this
account still in useful like you still
find people taking pics of you yeah all
the time I started I started that
account as an attempt to weaponize my
own annoyance with that thing that
people do the account became successful
and was so therapeutic that I didn't
really need to do it anymore they used
to really annoy me and then I got past
it and now I'm a better person thank you
guys for watching that was actually me
actually dylan sprouse undercover on the
internet it's actually me it's actually
me it's actually it's actually me me
it's actually me but a bing bada boom